hey I'm Tony Hawk pro skater and I have
been challenged to go through levels of
complexity in skateboard tricks in the
interest of time we are only covering
flat ground tricks and ramp tricks no
grinds no slides there are so many
variations here but I'm trying to give
you the foundation from which the other
ones are built and just remember this is
my personal interpretation of this
challenge so let's hit the floor level 1
would be the flat ground ollie
all these are the foundation to almost
every skate trick there's hardly any
tricks you can think of the don't start
with an ollie first so if you're gonna
start skating that's gonna be the first
trick that you actually learned the
motion of an ollie is using one foot to
snap the tail of the board downward and
then you have the board sort of aiming
up and then sliding your front foot at
the right time in order to bring that
board up and level it out in the air
it's a simple technique but it's all
about timing there are a lot of
subtleties to it there are all kinds of
different ways to ollie but the bottom
line is you're trying to get the board
up in the air only using your feet
people who first try to learn Ollie's
the number one mistake is they won't
commit to it so you see kids trying
Ollie's and they they land with their
foot off to the side people do that for
years and it's just all about committing
to actually landing on top of the board
level two is a 180 frontside ollie
frontside refers to the way that you're
turning and it all stems from surfing so
if your frontside to the wave
you're turning literally with your your
front facing the wave that translates
down to skateboarding where that same
motion is frontside on a frontside ollie
180 you can actually see where you're
going you can see the landing the motion
of it is basically an ollie and as you
ollie you're moving your shoulders and
you're turning your upper body 180 and
making your your lower body follow it's
a little bit of finesse with your feet
because your feet have to move a little
bit differently in order to make that
board come around and it's very easy to
have your back foot move too far which I
did plenty of times during this
demonstration once
and you're actually you're riding
backwards that makes it more complex as
well because you're starting the truck
forward you're landing backwards and a
lot of people are not comfortable going
backwards so level three I say is a
backside 180 ollie it's not that it's
more complex than a frontside 180 ollie
it's just a little bit more difficult
because you can't see your landing zone
so you're going literally on blind faith
that you're gonna be landing straight
and going the right direction and then
your head sort of catches up at the end
so it's almost like you're going with
the force you're using the force to land
properly and then using your other
senses to figure out where you are and
how to adjust it takes a little bit
different technique to with the snap on
the ollie because on the frontside Ollie
where you hit your tail is a little bit
different than on the backside one your
feet will move a little more on backside
generally and depending on how late you
turn the 180 is really how much risk
you're willing to put out there my level
four is a backside pop shuvit
what that means is turning the board a
180 under your feet while keeping your
body in the same position when I say
backside direction that means your board
is going the backside direction but your
body stays forward I would start with a
back side pop shove it first because I
feel like that's the easier way to do it
so 180s is the opposite but when you're
doing shove it's it's actually easier to
go back side because you can see the
board come around the idea is that you
snap it and as you snap the board you're
you're giving it a little nudge in that
direction and then you keep your feet
out of the way as it comes around and as
you see it come around you put your feet
back on the grip tape where it needs to
be and then push it down on the ground
it's very easy to spin it too far it's
very easy to spin it not enough as a
reference the first couple that I tried
today I overturned it so you can see
where my board goes a little bit too far
I caught it with my feet but my feet
kept going with it and it's just not
suitable for landing straight and it
just takes a little bit of finesse
because it really doesn't take a whole
lot of effort on your tail when you push
it to make it turn in fact some people
learn how to ollie accidentally
you pop shove-its because they can't
keep their board straight my level 5
would be a frontside pop shove-it
it's the same idea in theory as a
backside pop shuvit but you're pushing
the board the other direction you're
pushing it more of an unnatural way
because you have to sort of kick it in
front of you yet
the board stays so far under your feet
it's hard to see so this trick is more
based on feeling than sight you'll see
that when my feet are set up my feet are
very exaggerated off from one side of
the tail and off from one side of the
nose I need that in order to keep the
board flat as they kick it around if you
keep your feet in the general Ollie
position and try a frontside pop
shove-it it's very likely the board will
flip and not flip in a good way you're
gonna land either upside down or what we
call prima which is on your wheels
sideways and that usually doesn't turn
out very well either
I feel like some people find a trick
that that they're comfortable with and
that becomes their go-to even though it
might be a few levels above what's basic
perfect example is my son Spencer he
doesn't skate regularly but when he does
skate he could do frontside pop
shove-its easily clean catch them high
and it's just like this muscle memory he
has which is fascinating to me because
mine are terrible level 6 in my eyes is
a kickflip it's crazy to think that many
people understand what a kickflip is
these days because when we first saw
rodney mullen do it we didn't understand
how he made his board flip we called it
a magic flip that was literally the name
of it at first he called a nollie flip
because he did ollie first and then flip
the board and that is the technique and
the baseline of it isn't ollie but as
you're ollieing and as your foot is
sliding forward to level out the board
it actually slides out to the side and
starts it flipping it's all one fluid
motion it's a foundation of skating but
it also could be one of the hardest
things to learn the whole idea is that
you're doing an ollie and you're making
the board flip under your feet a lot can
go wrong like that usually it doesn't
flip enough I did that plenty of times
have been doing this segment and the
whole reason for that is that you either
didn't flick it fast enough or you
didn't ollie high enough you can always
improve your kickflips the idea is you
want to catch them high you want to get
to your feet so you're still under
control of the board as you're in the
air if we had levels of kickflips the
first level is doing it the second level
it's catching it and the third level is
doing it over stuff over stairs over
fire hydrants flipping into tricks level
seven for me would be a heel flip it's a
little bit misleading to say it's the
actual heel flip because you're not
using your heel to flip it so you see
that the kickflip turns this one
direction and when you see a heel flip
it turns the opposite direction you're
not actually flipping it with your heel
but that's the only way it's to separate
those two terms and as you see my foot
is set up actually with my heel off to
the other side of the board I'm actually
scraping the side of my foot diagonally
the opposite direction of a kickflip but
I'm not using my heel I'm still using
the toes and my on my shoe to make it
happen
and sliding it that way and then making
a flop over number one mistake of heel
flips not getting it around landing
Premo and following backwards some
people find it easier to flip heel flips
including one of my kids all of this can
be can be debated it's really more
personal preference but in my head and I
learned kick flips first other in heel
flips much later ironically for me heel
flips are easier on vert but I'll get to
that later level eight is what is
commonly known as a varial flip which is
actually a misnomer because to do a
varial you have to grab your board and
turn it with your hand so it's actually
a shove it kick flip that is what it
should be called but I'm gonna go with
the general population and say okay it's
a varial flip basically it's a shove it
and a kick flip
all at once what happens is you flick
the board you actually position your
foot so that you're kicking it and
giving it a little twist at the same
time so that when it does come around a
kickflip ends up landing like a heel
flip sometimes that's easier than a heel
flip because you get to see the board
come around and you can decide when you
want actually
put your feet down on it like when it's
going to be safe to land it's a building
block to other tricks so this level with
the varial flip or the shove-it kickflip
is a little bit more complicated because
any shuvit kickflip could be considered
on the same level which is a varial
heelflip and inward heel flip or a hard
flip and all of those are the board's
spinning different directions and doing
different types of flips and then you
get into spinning the body more you can
do big flips you do 360 flips laser
flips there's all kinds of other ways to
do this so I'm just gonna leave that all
in the same level and for other people
to decide which ones are more difficult
in the interest of time and being
concise I'm excluding a lot of other
ways to do these tricks including going
backwards going fakie doing them switch
doing them your unnatural stance there
is a whole sea of different ways to do
this and I'm not ignoring them I'm just
trying to focus on the basis and the
foundation of what these tricks are so
in order to go to the next level of
complexity I need to get more airtime
and I do that by using my vertical
halfpipe because it actually propels me
into the air six to ten feet and that
way I can show you what it's like to
ollie and start spinning and doing more
complex maneuvers so let's go hit the
vert here we are on the ramp this is
where I'm gonna be able to show you more
aerial tip maneuvers spinning maneuvers
180 360 540 this level of complexity is
a little more dangerous there's more
airtime you're going a lot faster there
is very little room for error
you can come crashing down from 20 feet
very easily but this is what I grew up
skating and this is where I feel most
comfortable so here we go level 9 would
be a 180 aerial and what that means is
going up the ramp going to the top
getting in the air turning 180 degrees
and coming back down the same side of
the ramp so I am always going forward
and I'm gonna show it to you backside
because I think that's one of the
easiest ones to learn and when you do a
backside aerial that's usually a way to
gain speed for a harder trick going up
the next wall so level 10 is a 360
aerial that can be done a number of ways
you can go backwards and do it you can
go up forwards and land backwards I'm
going to show you what I think is the
most basic 360 aerial and that is a
frontside 360 so I'm going up the ramp
I'm turning in the frontside direction a
full 360 and I'm coming down backwards
so you may think the next level of
complexity is a 540 aerial for some
people that might be true but I believe
that before we get into a 540 aerial I
want to get into a flip trick flipping
the board in the air and catching it
under my feet while doing a 180 for me
that would be a frontside 180 heelflip
so you remember at level seven on the
flat ground which was the heel flip this
is what it looks like when you take the
heel flip onto a vert ramp in the air
and turn a 180 at the same time so this
is where we start adding levels of
complexity danger and difficulty so the
next level would be a 540 spin I would
choose to do a backside 540 spin more
commonly known as am a twist the way
that I grab it it was the first backside
540 ever done on a vert ramp which was
on my Mike McGill this can turn into
more of a flip sometimes but the level
of complexity and difficulty is much
greater because you are blind to the
ramp for half the spin that means you
cannot see your landing zone until
you're just coming around and it's
almost too late to try to worry about it
so going forward I'm going to use
existing videos of tricks because in the
interest of time and my own personal
safety these tricks are much more
complex and require a lot more effort
and a lot more attempts luckily I have
some on video and we can refer to those
level 13 is a 720 spin it's a trick I
created in 1985 because I had a ramp
that was giving me plenty of airtime at
some point I realized I could probably
spend more than a 540 on this ramp and
it worked out pretty well you come up
backwards spin around almost do two
somersaults and then come down forward
720 s are especially difficult because
you are blind to the ramp for a
uncomfortable long time the eye
you're coming up backwards and starting
a spin makes it extra difficult because
it's hard to snap off the wall to get
enough air time in the world of
skateboarding that snap is what it's all
about especially on a vert ramp level 14
is a very ohmic twist so if you remember
the pop shuvit on flat ground and the
McTwist maneuver this is combining those
two things in a much more complicated
and complex way you're spinning the
board an extra 180 under your feet as
you spin this one and a half somersault
in the air the board does two full
rotations you do one and a half
you've got to meet it with your feet
before you're ready to land and a lot of
that is just based on feeling level 15
in going with this pattern to me would
be a kickflip McTwist I can't explain
how much more difficult that is then
these other tricks let's put it this way
the McTwist wasn't created in 1984 the
very oma twist was created in 1989 and
the kickflip missed didn't happen until
1995 it's that much harder because
you're flipping your board you're trying
to set it into the same trajectory of
spin that you're doing with your body
and at the same time you've got to catch
it as it kick flips one rotation so all
that's happening without you being able
to see your board or your landing zone
it all happens almost in a vacuum while
you're flipping and you're spinning and
all these things have to come together
and it's all based on feeling once I
flip it and I feel the board in my hand
and I feel my hand near my feet all
systems go it doesn't always work but
that's the only that's the only way that
I can gauge if it's gonna happen at all
this was my very first kick foot my
twist it happened in 1995 on one of the
few vert ramps in the world that was in
Tampa Florida at the skate park of Tampa
vert skating was relatively dead there
was only a handful of hardcore vert
skaters left in the world and we all
happened to be there that night I just
made it happen this trick I've been
testing and testing and testing and I
knew that if I was never gonna make it
it was
to be this time with my contemporaries
so if you see where I'm landing on the
ramp that's not the ideal landing zone
but I managed to absorb that impact just
based on experience in hindsight I
needed to land that low because I needed
all that time to make all the other
things happen I made it a few times
since then maybe a little bit cleaner
but I'm I'm hugely proud of this one
because it was the first one and you can
tell the elation on my face and just how
excited everybody else was it's weird to
think that that kind of progression was
happening in this very small scene of
skateboarding I mean that wasn't gonna
make an ESPN highlight or anything it
was just more of a cool thing that
happened in the skateboard world level
16 would be doing a 720 spin and adding
a board variation to that my board
variation of choice for the first time
doing it was a varial 720 the board does
a full 900 rotation and my body does a
720 rotation spinning around twice and
trying to get your board to your feet
during that double spin is extra hard
because basically once you leave your
board you kind of leave it behind and
see if you got to rely on your feet
kicking the board into an extra spin as
you catch it and guide it around if that
sounds difficult it is
if you ever see someone trying Verrill
720s you'll see them kind of lagging
with their board behind and they never
get back to their feet correctly and the
key to it is getting that snap kicking
your feet extra hard and getting the
board to start spinning before you even
start spinning your body we're talking
about fractions of a second to make that
work and even then it might not work
level 17 of spinning arrow maneuvers for
me would be a 900
to give up some perspective I learned
Verrill 720s in 1998 and then learned
900 that in 1999 basically a 900 is
extra tricky because twice you're blind
to your landing zone you need plenty of
airtime as you come around
you've got to shift your weight mid spin
in order to not fall too far forward I'd
say that's the first mistake of anyone
learning 900s once they actually try to
land it on the wall you end up falling
forward into the bottom of the ramp and
a McTwist you don't have to shift your
weight like that but once you're coming
around and you're spinning another 360
on the way down you've got to make sure
that you balance your weight evenly it's
a very nuanced shift into your back foot
and it can't be too much and even then
you don't know if it's gonna work the
complexity of a 900 is not necessarily
higher than any of these other tricks
the danger factor is much higher because
if you miss any part of that spin or if
you open up during that spin you find
yourself in midair way over the ramp and
falling on your back and it happens all
the time
even if I miss the grab I have to commit
my body to that spin just to land safely
and I know that just sounds bizarre the
idea that you already know you're
falling but you've got to commit to the
whole trick because otherwise you're
gonna land on your back and the flat
bottom I have broken my rib on it I've
broken my ego many a times trying to
make it happen I had been trying 900s
for about 10 years before I actually
made one when I finally made one it felt
it just felt like a huge relief it was
more like oh I can just put that one to
rest no more getting hurt on that so to
leave level 17 and go into level 18 when
we just add one more 180 spin we need to
leave this realm of size of ramps
because it requires much more air time
Shaun White almost got 10 days on ramps
this size but truly you need something
where you're gonna get at least 10 to 15
feet of air just to spin that fast the
next level of difficulty would be a 1080
spin
[Music]
you come up backwards three full
somersault rotations and then come back
down forward I honestly have never even
tried one because you need a much bigger
ramp to get that kind of air time and
you have to be going at that ramp going
backwards and those two things just were
not in my in my wheelhouse the guy who
did a first was Tom Shar he was known
for his spinning maneuvers on ramps he
was much smaller so he could ball up
tightly and he was very comfortable on
what we now know as the mega ramp the
mega ramp is usually one big long jump
and then after you land that jump you go
into this giant quarter pipe they
covered that jump for Tom for this so he
could just focus on the one trick so he
would come in backwards roll over the
what used to be the jump and then he had
the right amount of speed for this 1080
it was hugely monumental when it
happened only one other person has done
it since then it's still one of the most
difficult biggest milestones in
skateboarding as far as I'm concerned
especially in ramps this could be argued
but I believe the next level of
complexity would be a flip trick with a
720 we're gonna remove a full 360 from
this trick of a 1080 and add another
board variation flip into it instead of
three spins it's two spins but at a heel
flip way harder as far as I'm concerned
the reason being is that you're coming
up backwards and to make that snap
coming up backwards and get the board
flipping and your body spinning all on
the same plane requires an intense level
of focus an intense level of airtime and
everything has to come together
perfectly I'm telling you this because
I've never done it but our team writer
Elliot Sloan has done it a couple times
and it is hugely impressive when he does
it
I watched him try this trick for almost
three hours straight and make it once
and it was worth it basically what you
see in the beginning is that snap that
I've been talking about where you're
snapping it off the wall trying to get
enough air time and distance away from
the coping to make the full rotation as
he's snapping you see his foot do this
very quick motion sending the
into a heelflip and as that's happening
he makes sure that it's also not just
flipping but spinning with his body
and his hand is just in the position to
catch it he hopes that it comes around
back into his hand and that is the key
to this whole trick is is the flip and
the catch and when it actually happens
and he feels it in his hand under his
feet he just throws it on the wall and
he doesn't even know if it's gonna work
when you get to this level of ramp
skating that's what it takes is
sometimes just a Hail Mary
so for these next levels of complexities
I think that we're gonna go into the
realm of unreality because these are NB
DS which means they've never been done
but we know as skaters of this ilk that
they are possible level 20 would be
something that has never been done in
nvd and it would be an alley 720 which
means you go up the ramp and do a full
double rotation without grabbing the
board and MIDI and so the last final
level to end this list is something that
has not only never been done but I've
never seen it attempted although with
the size of ramps and with the
experience level of some of these
skaters that are growing up riding these
ramps doing it at age 10 I feel like is
on the horizon and that would be a 1260
spin three and a half rotations going up
the ramp forward 900 out of 360 to the
900 come back down forward I know that
there are people that have been
discussing it it's very possible that
we'll see one in our lifetime
[Music]
what can I say it actually got done
recently by Mitchie Brusco he was the
only one to even try it in fact I don't
think he ever practiced it before he
made the one he did that's where it lies
that is the absolute apex of spinning
maneuvers on ramps you're lucky to see
in your lifetime it's hard to say that
even though an ollie 720 hasn't been
done that that's somehow harder than a
1260 that has been done the 1260 is just
the danger factor and the difficulty and
the spinning there's so many things that
could go horribly wrong tragically wrong
on that trick that I have still would
keep it as the top level of complexity
and difficulty even though all these 720
is still an NBD so I'm choosing to end
this list here because I feel like it's
a pretty good summary of different
aerial type maneuvers or all a type
maneuvers there are so many variations
of these tricks that you could go to
exponential levels of complexity and
difficulty skateboarding can be as
complex as you want it to be I think
skateboarding at its base is a form of
expression and for me it is my art form
it's also a sport it's also a lifestyle
but as very core it's your voice and you
can do it in any style in any form you
choose the possibilities are endless and
I hope that this gives you a glimpse
into the difficulties and complexity of
skateboarding especially through my eyes
okay thanks wired hope it helped
[Music]